alors attend encore une chance de
trouver une issue dans cette crise
ukrainienne avec notamment ces
négociations demain viennent au delà des
déclarations des uns et des autres quels
enjeux au centre de ces échanges
occident russie c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
tout d'abord général dominique trinquant
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous un expert
en géostratégie à nos côtés également en
direct par skype régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france ainsi que nicolas
mirkovic analyste politique
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors on le voit général
trinquons les rendez vous diplomatiques
qui s'enchaînent qui ne se ressemblent
pas nécessairement mais quand même pour
trouver un accord et la situation qui
semble bloquée malgré les déclarations
de bonnes intentions excepté quand même
ce constat de divergence fondamentale
avec l'otan selon les les russes on peut
parler d'un dialogue de sourds entre
l'otan et la russie alors le premier
point ça qu'on peut parler de dialogue
on rappelle que le dialogue otan russie
avaient été suspendus il y a deux ans et
demi les russes décidant qu'il n'y avait
plus de dialogue à avoir avec le temps
et donc il est heureux qu'aujourd'hui ce
dialogue ait lieu alors quand on s'est
tu pendant deux ans et demi évidemment
ça prouve à prendre un peu de temps pour
se mettre d'accord pour progresser 1 le
dialogue c'est toujours des des
concessions de part et d'autre bon bah
je pense que le premier round c'est
simplement de mesurer quelle est la
position de chacun des des
interlocuteurs à laurent les positions
elles sont assez claires en tout cas du
côté de la russie à cette ligne rouge
évidemment à la politique de portes
ouvertes de l'otan moscou la jugent
comme clairement une menace pour sa
sécurité
nicolas miskovic c'est légitime tout
même de de vouloir empêcher des
activités militaires proches de la
frontière russe je pense que la russie a
clairement montré donc sa ligne rouge et
la russie est dans son droit n'oublions
pas que ce sont les soldats les armées
de l'otan qui depuis des années ne cesse
de mener des actions des exercices
militaires le long de la frontière russe
que ce sont ces le camp atlantiste et
washington qui éclaire mais clairement à
organiser forme et pousser à des
sédition et des révolutions de coûts en
ukraine en géorgie en arménie c'est à
dire cela contient russe ou d'un moment
il est légitime qu'une nation souveraine
disent qu'ils ne veulent plus qu'une
organisation étrangère vienne l'a
titillé l'excité la provoquer sur sa
propre frontière c'est tout à fait
légitime mais je pense qu'en définition
cette liste deux camps gardés que le que
la russie veut négocier avec avec
washington la russie montrent que la
nuit rouge a clairement été franchi et
qu'il est temps de se mettre à la table
des négociations sinon un incident grave
va arriver la diplomatie russe ce n'est
pas caché lors de notre côté c'est vrai
qu on
reproche le jeu aux russes de s'attaquer
à la souveraineté évidemment de de
l'ukraine c'est vrai que régis le
sommier pour rebondir sur ce que disait
nicolas avenir cowitz on se souvient
qu'au lendemain de du chute du mur de
berlin les américains avaient vraiment
promis à la russie de ne surtout pas
étendre l'otan s'étaient déjà à l'époque
la ligne rouge il ya ce sentiment
effectivement de trahison de confiance
rompue que ressent la l'émir poutine
aujourd'hui satan c'est un question
oui tout d'abord il ya une dizaine de
pays en gros de dexter up de l'est qui
ont rejoint ou l'otan ou comment l'union
européenne donc c'est sûr que la russie
a tendance quand on voit de son point de
vue de voir justement le monde
occidental s'approcher de ses frontières
et aujourd'hui on arrive au cas ultime
puisque à la fois sur la question de la
géorgie et la question de l'ukraine il y
à un risque pour la russie que ces deux
pays décident enfin décide ou en tout
cas ce oasis de rejoindre l'organisation
du traité de l'atlantique nord et ça
c'est pour les russes on l'a dit on va
on va pas revenir là dessus
éternellement mais c'est quelque chose
qui est insupportable qui n'est pas peut
être pas de l'ordre du possible
maintenant sur la situation en effet
elle les critiques en effet il y a de
part et d'autre des forces mobilisées 1
dans les pays baltes par exemple vous
avez des forces françaises à l'heure
actuelle faut le savoir le pignon
publique française ne l'est pas n'est
pas forcément informés de ça mais en
tout cas là ans participent et d'autres
pays à des manoeuvres aussi et de
l'autre côté la russie et bien la
situation ont dit oui les chars sont
massés aux frontières
regardant les choses dans leur réalité
depuis 2014 il y à environ 70 milles
troupes russes qui sont sur la frontière
ukrainienne il y a dans l'est de
l'ukraine des commandes et des tranchées
avec on est dans un état quasiment de
guerre et deux fois par an en gros en
russie il y à des manoeuvres militaires
qui monte qui feront monter ce nombre de
soldats de 70 à 100 milles environ
massés aux frontières actuellement la
question c'est qu'une partie de l'armée
ukrainienne a été renforcée je les ai
déjà dit sur cette antenne mais par des
missiles antichars par des drones par
des à des équipements plus modernes et
que la russie elle attend dé s'adapte en
protégeant ses chars donc il ya eu une
escalade technologique on dirait qu'ils
existent mais en tout cas pour ce qui
est des manoeuvres des uns et des autres
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
existe depuis des mines 2014 et depuis
le début de la crise ukrainienne puisque
je le rappelle les accords de minsk
n'ont jamais étaient appliquées le
gouvernement de kiev n'a jamais négocié
avec les républiques de l'est de
l'ukraine et ce qui était prévu dans le
cadre de commandes de ces accords les
accords n'ont en réalité jamais été
appliquée donc cette situation de guerre
larvée elle existe depuis un moment à la
frontière avec sonia et on voit que la
confiance est évidemment arts a du mal à
se faire entre les deux camps si j'ose
dire washington donc on lisait un qui a
accusé moscou de vouloir envahir
l'ukraine malgré de multiples démentis
que peu que devrait faire général
trinquant moscou pour convaincre les
occidentaux d' de sa bonne foi
la première chose serait de ne pas
dramatiser quand j'entends les pays de
l'est qu'on appelait les pays de l'est
autrefois qui ont rejoint l'europe et
autant je voudrais rappeler simplement
que ces pays étaient les pays occupés
par l'union soviétique autres temps
autres moeurs si j'ose dire on n'est
plus tout à fait dans cette
configuration on ait pu face à l'union
soviétique mais avec la russie qui doit
dialoguer avec les européens aujourd'hui
on voit bien que dans le dialogue on
parlait de l'accord de mines tout à
l'heure c'est le format qu'on appelait
format normandie or qui était en pointe
de de discussions avec la russie c'était
l'allemagne et la france or là monsieur
poutine a réussi son coup si j'ose dire
c'est je suis un grand jeu discutent
directement avec monsieur byden est
directement avec les états unis donc je
crois que il faut revenir à la réalité
des choses nous n'avons pu de l'autre
côté une d'un côté une idéologie qui
était l'idéologie soviétique qui
occupaient des pays européen mais des
pays européens perrin qui ont librement
choisi avec des élections avec des votes
de rejoindre l'europe alors aujourd'hui
la question se pose essentiellement en
ukraine où il ya une conflagration en
ukraine est effectivement là il ya des
tensions très importante avec d'une part
des forces russes importante à la
frontière et de l'autre côté un soutien
apporté à l'ukraine puisque l'ukraine
aujourd'hui dit qu'elle elle veut régler
le problème donc il faut revenir un
petit peu comme cela a été cité à
l'accord la corde minsk et que kiev n'a
pas appliqué je suis d'accord également
et il faut revenir en abaissant les
tensions et en ne refusant pas le jeu
des empires s'affrontant si je veux dire
ça n'est plus de l'époque nicolas
mirkovic ya aussi cet aspect aujourd'hui
devant les opinions respectives de des
présidents de ne pas peut-être
s'abaisser à dialoguer c'est peut-être
le cas de joe biden on en a déjà parlé
d'ailleurs lundi c'est une forme de
faiblesse de négocier avec le président
russe ont en tout cas pour les
démocrates et dans l'opinion américaine
je pense que ce jeu de type de
négociation se fait dans le temps c'est
ce sont les négociations extrêmement
importante et c'est normal qu'à ce stade
là on va en retrouvant au premier rang
et baden et poutine qui sont déjà
rencontrés en juin dernier à genève il y
avait déjà une porte qui était ouvert au
dialogue là ce ne sont pas des seconds
couteaux ce sont des techniciens des
spécialistes qui vont se retrouver dans
les différentes réunions qui sont
organisées cette semaine je pense que
c'est pas une forme de faiblesse même si
on a vu que côte est des états unis pour
la première fois et commence à invoquer
des menaces ou des sanctions directement
entre vladimir poutine je ne savais pas
du tout l'esprit de ces discussions là
où techniquement les attentistes vont
regarder les propositions russes ils
vont discuter vont dialoguer c'est tout
à fait normal à ce stade là des
discussions il n'y a pas d'autres
interprétations costard à voir alors
effectivement gsee le sommaire les
menacent de lourdes pénalités
économiques un des nouvelles
implantations sur ces négociations
on parle de sanction inédite évidemment
ça va souvent débattu ici de leur
efficacité je vous propose d'ailleurs de
regarder cette carte 1 quand on sait que
la russie aux loyers sur cette carte
exporte donc 40% de son gaz en europe on
peut se poser la question finalement de
kiss sorel le plus perdant est ce que de
ce point de vue là l'europe est un petit
peu coincé tout même
alors l'europe malheureusement une bonne
comment on n'a pas tellement voix au
chapitre alors elle est consultée mais
comme le disait le général traquant tout
à l'heure les admire poutine est ravi de
parler directement et de ne plus
inscrire justement dans dans ces formats
dialogue avec la france et l'allemagne
la question du gaz et la question
énergétique et la question aussi des
sanctions parce que la russie est sous
l'objet de sanctions c'est que
aujourd'hui l'europe est
particulièrement l'allemagne a une
fragilité vis-à-vis de la russie savait
que la russie avec l'accord comment avec
le gazoduc nord stream n'est plus
contrainte de faire passer son gaz par
l'ukraine et ce gaz arrive directement
en allemagne il ya eu d'ailleurs des
légères interruption de gaz comment
comme un petit peu un signal de moscou
qu'on pourrait couper les robinets et si
on coupe les robinets en plein hiver en
allemagne est particulièrement dans la
dans la partie orientale de l'allemagne
vient c'est des milliers ni millions de
personnes qui peuvent se retrouver sans
chauffage et ça c'est un c'est un vrai
problème basque et donc il ya deux
gazoducs aya nord stream et nord stream
2 et sa d'une salle dont certains
bassins pas une certaine façon
l'allemagne est particulièrement comment
ils se diraient
vulnérables vis-à-vis de 2,2 de
commandes la russie alors qu'il faut
savoir aussi une chose c'est que on l'a
vu depuis un petit moment
l'administration byden ne considèrent
comment en europe qu'un seul
interlocuteur l'allemagne et la russie
de son côté également considère
l'allemagne est assez peu les autres
acteurs on en est malheureusement nous
français même les anglais comment et les
italiens encore plus à faire de la
figuration dans cette espèce de
gigantesque bras de fer qui est en train
de se jouer à l'est et on a vu en effet
que d'un côté donc va l'ennemi routine
dialogue directement avec le président
américain et de l'autre côté aussi il
faut prendre en compte que joe biden a
une très mauvaise cote dans son opinion
publique aujourd'hui que les élections
de mi mandat sont en train d'arriver et
que qu'il risque de les perdre donc la
tentation comme tout président américain
qui arrive aux élections de mi mandat
c'est justement d'agiter le a6 fond
d'une menace internationale et là ça
tombe à pic pour baden pour montrer que
il est capable de montrer ses muscles
parce que n'oublions pas que byron paye
encore aujourd'hui dans l'opinion
publique américaine le retrait
désastreux d'afghanistan et que les
républicains sont décidés justement à ne
pas lui faire oublier donc bye donne a
intérêt à montrer aussi que vis-à-vis de
poutine et vis-à-vis des russes il a un
discours ferme donc on est sur un
mélange à la fois effectivement de
données comme vous l'avez dit économique
pèse d'or sur ces négociations mais il
ne faut pas oublier la question des
opinions publiques nationales et la
question de la réalité des agendas
électoraux au moment où on parle et où
résiste sommet derrière on nous disait
que les français l'europe et en
particuliers notamment les français
n'ont pas vraiment voix au chapitre on
apprend à l'instant que par les dépêches
que jean yves le drian déclarent
préférer une stratégie de détente plutôt
qu'un bras de fer avec la russie ça dit
quoi ça on a connu jean yves le drian
plus voilà plus hostiles aux russes et
on n'a pas le choix aujourd'hui il faut
être pragmatique il faut être
pragmatique et de toutes façons il n'y a
que le dialogue qui paiera je ne crois
absolument pas à des divisions russe qui
vont aller vers kiev je n'y crois
absolument pas donc il s'agit de
détendre et il s'agit de discuter la
discussion autour aujourd hui
d'aujourd'hui pardon et et otan russie
demain c'est l'eau et c'est eux et l'eau
et c est un format beaucoup plus large
et c'est la sécurité en europe
complètement qu'il faut reprendre en
compte parce que effectivement on peut
comprendre d'une côté les anciens pays
dont je rappelle toujours qu'ils étaient
occupés par l'union soviétique qui
aujourd'hui ont peur de ce qu'on appelle
l'ours russe et les français qui ont
toujours eu tendance à vouloir dialoguer
avec la russie il faut amener les gens à
ce dialogue et c'est vrai que ce qui
vient d'être appelé est très juste il
faut voir aussi les problèmes intérieurs
l'allemagne vient d'avoir des élections
hélas ces problèmes d'énergie et
monsieur barry donne lui s'annonce vers
des élections qui risquent d'être
catastrophiques pour lui pas
catastrophique au sens où il risque de
perdre la majorité et donc tous ces
éléments doivent être pris en compte et
c'est pour ça que je parle de ce
dialogue il est dommage qu'il ait été
arrêté pendant deux ans et demi parce
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à le reprendre
après deux ans et demi de silence mais
il est homme le faire nicholas markowitz
dans votre point de vue
quelle est aujourd'hui l'issue
effectivement la plus probable dans dans
cette crise qu'elle est en tout cas vous
votre lecture
je pense que c'était déjà bien c'est
qu'ils ont effectué cette porte vers le
dialogue qui a été ouverte déjà depuis
l'été dernier qui va se poursuivre ce
problème ne va pas se régler du jour au
lendemain on sait que la russie a
demandé une réponse à l'otan avant son
1er choc prochain sommet au mois de juin
prochain j'espère que ça va aller vite
je pense que c'est assez important que
le monde que le monde occidental
comprennent que les russes eux n'en
peuvent plus des sanctions injustes de
la part des états unis les sanctions qui
ruine les sanctions européennes qui
ruinent avant tout les agriculteurs les
entreprises européennes qui ne peuvent
plus exporter sur le marché russe les
russes depuis longtemps ont compris que
s'il ne pouvait pas faire plus faire
affaire avec les uns avec les européens
de l'ouest est blasé les faire affaire
avec d'autres sous d'autres pays voire
même lancé leurs propres économies mais
qu'ils veulent avant tout être ce qu'ils
ont toujours été c'est à dire une
puissance européenne le l'exemple du
gazoduc north stream 2 est un exemple
parfait c'est un projet 100% européen
entre russes et d'autres sociétés
européennes et qu'est-ce qui nous qu'est
ce qui bloque ce projet ce sont les
états unis donc du coup je pense que la
russie a montré que c'était fini qu'elle
n'allait plus encaisser les coups comme
bout d'un moment il était temps que
réaliste qu'elle montre que la ligne
rouge était non seulement proche mais
qu'elle habitait franchie mais qu'elle
était prête maintenant à se défendre
avec les manades avec les moyens qu'il a
définie a qui sont tus peut-être aux
militaires ou alternative parce que du
coup on a trop joué avec la russie et je
pense que ce qui est important c'est que
cela réveille un petit peu les nations
européennes qui se rend compte qu'elles
sont le dindon de la farce dans ces
négociations puisque il n'y a en effet
pas de nation européenne présents dans
ce dialogue entre la la la ce sur des
crises qui concerne les états unis et ou
qui concerne pardon des pays européens
washington est à plus de dix mille
kilomètres des républiques du nom basse
ont du coup on et j'espère quand même
que certaines nations européennes vont
se rendre compte qu'il est temps
qu'elles rentrent dans les négociations
qu'ils puissent exprimer leur voix et
que les pays européens trouvent une
issue entre et elles n'ont pas besoin de
l'aide de washington ni des états unis
voir et c'est ça le saunier justement
sur ces propos nicolas
mirkovic qui dit en substance
la rue s'il tend vers vers l'europe
parce que ce n'est pas cela le fond de
la question la russie qui a tout
simplement envie d'être reconnus
respectés
à la tv réalité si j'ose dire moi je
vais pas vous dire le contraire j'ai
toujours prôné justement un
rapprochement notamment à la russie non
mais je pense que je pense qu'il ya
matière à rapprochement je parle pas
d'ailleurs uniquement de la russie je
pense que vis-à-vis la turquie également
on ne peut pas laisser aux périphérie de
l'europe parce que ça nous concerne
directement des pays qui ont des
comportements oui il existe des tensions
il faut absolument dialoguer avec ces
pays il faut absolument reprendre langue
avec eux la question de l'ukraine doit
être résolue d'une façon ou d'une autre
on le sent bien les etats unis sont
attachés à la souveraineté de l'ukraine
ça a l'air d'être très important pour
eux et d'un autre côté la russe la
russie devait absolument pas de l'otan à
ses frontières il faut je pense qu'on
peut trouver dans cette note dans ce
cadre une forme de je vais dire de
finlandisation de l'ukraine et de la
géorgie savez la finlande était restée
une sorte de pays neutre entre l'est et
l'ouest à l'issue de la première guerre
mondiale de la deuxième guerre mondiale
pardon et est
faux que là il faut que les deux points
de vue d'une certaine façon soit
respectée et que les européens aussi
fassent un effort pour parler d'une même
voix parce que là on sent à chaque fois
qu'il y à des tensions ou des des
manières différentes de voir la
situation est aujourd'hui on est revenu
à un dialogue comme je le disais tout à
l'heure entre bayonne et poutine entre
russes et américains et ça n'est pas
nécessairement dans nos intérêts ça
n'est pas dans les intérêts de la france
et la france peut-être à une carte à
jouer ou à des cartes différentes à
jouer aujourd'hui d'autant que la france
reste un pays respecté avec une arme est
formidable et des intérêts dans le monde
et il faut qu'elle fasse entendre le
savoir en dehors
c'est un mauvais bond de de vous
répondre oui non quand vous êtes moins
ne pas lui couper la parole à je
voudrais simplement rappeler que le
dialogue entre la russie et les
européens c'est monsieur poutine qui l'a
bail passé c'est monsieur poutine qui a
voulu discuter avec les américains
directement pour se placer au niveau des
grands et donc à évacuer le dise que la
discussion avec les européens ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point quant
à la géorgie et l'ukraine je voudrais
rappeler qu'il y a des années que la
georgie et l'ukraine ont demandé à
rejoindre le temps et c'est l'allemagne
et la france qui ont mis leur veto et
qui ont dit non parce qu'il savait que
c'était trop dangereux donc je crois que
tout le monde a raison il faut que les
européens reviennent dans cette
discussion mais encore faudrait-il que
monsieur poutine le veut le veuille
aujourd'hui pour son opinion nationale
il est bien plus j'ai à dire en posture
il est bien plus satisfait de discuter
directement avec les états unis merci
non régis repartait pas pour deux pour
15 minutes à lésiner vraiment vite à la
démo vient quand même deux choses très
différentes je suis d'accord avec le
l'analyse du général traquant bien quand
même deux choses différentes qui se sont
produites ces derniers temps et je pense
que vous ne pouvez pas les ignorer c'est
le double départ des américains
d'afghanistan rugby décrété et qui est
fait sans consultation des alliés et
puis cette fameuse affaire de sous
marins australiens où on se passe de
nous demander notre avis donc le
problème avec les américains aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on veut bien dialoguer mais on
veut bien avoir des alliés mais encore
faudrait-il qu entre alliés on se parle
et qu'on arrête de se comporter de cette
façon là merci en tout cas à tous les
trois régis le sommier nicolas mirkovic
est raccord merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france